foreign
[Music]
welcome to Stanford what a magical place
you know it's uh it's kind of an amazing
place to be right you feel a little
smarter walking from the parking lot to
the cafeteria
you know I uh I'm in the sales business
um
and I spent a lot of time kind of
studying the subject matter
because uh I am a I'm a husband and
father of four
and uh
it's my job to provide for these for
kids right feed them you know clothe
them provide education all that kind of
thing but we're also a Frugal family
right so I like going to the second hand
stores and uh I picked up all these
National Geographic Magazines at the
second hand store but the one I like the
most is this one here
the new science of the teenage brain
so
how would you like to be a teenager
again
let's think on this just a little bit
no I don't think so
well in the article talks about teenage
brain temerity so teenagers are crazy
they jump off the roof of the house they
drive too fast they talk to strangers
they also have brain cognition mapping
so they take a
they take an experience and they begin
to build this experience
then when they want to do something new
they go back to that brain map and do it
again
but we also know that the hey they're
teenagers so the experience is more
important than the logic
so I know this for a fact because uh
you know I get reprimanded at my house
most of the time because
they're telling me hey Dad get off the
roof and why are you driving so fast why
are you talking to all those people you
know you might get abducted you know
kidnapped or something we don't have
Ransom money for you so I think that my
brain is stuck in adolescent Adventure
Mode
and to prove my point let me take you
back to 1983 where Steve Jobs is 28
years old you can buy a hamburger for 15
cents and also went to Europe for two
weeks
but once they are remember the words of
Benjamin Franklin that guests and fish
are the same that begin to stink after
three days so because of that I resorted
to hitchhiking but I didn't know how to
do it so I had to kind of figure it out
it's so unnerving getting some
stranger's vehicle
so this uh two-week vacation ended up to
becoming a two-year Odyssey I just
hitchhiked and had odd jobs for these
two years it was crazy
learn a lot about myself during this
time I learned that I love the adventure
I love the adrenaline I like starting
new things meeting new people new places
but I also have a problem
you know what do you do when you enter a
vagabond just does not want to get along
with you it's always kind of let's go to
the next thing
so when I started my sales career I had
to uh had to rethink this because well
often time I felt like I was hitchhiking
again
so I started studying the brain of the
hitchhiker so here it is
so this blue area is the adventure
and we spent a lot of time on the road
kind of looking at the cars looking at
this go to market strategy here I need
to get a ride
then this yellow this yellow one here
is the adrenaline so exciting when you
actually get picked up especially if
it's a red Lamborghini which never
stopped then this green one here this is
the money
so we got to our destination we got to
do it all over again
it feels like a
feels like a sales life cycle
so here's here's what scientists tell us
this is a brain schema take the
predominant experience begin to build
upon this over and over again
so what we believe
what we believe to be true
what we listen to what we read who our
advisors are who our mentors are all
matter
it begins to build a brain map inside of
us and we live off these brain Maps
so what is your brain schema telling you
I want to know more about it
1990 I made my first company and it was
successful because I was at the right
place at the right time
and because of this I didn't know what
to do when the when my future work
changed so my company became my best
teacher but also my absolute worst
Tormentor because I have a teenage brain
you know I you know Adventure adrenaline
repeat that's how I live my life and ran
the company
so I have hitchhiker brain
over the last 10 years I've had the
privilege of coaching and Consulting
Rising Star Executives and also Founders
on their go to market strategies
and in doing this work I found some
similarities between learning and also
um the adventure so complicated graph
let me explain it this is part Simon
sinek Park Black Swan part Blue Ocean
strategy and Part Stanford left hand
side's the money down below is the time
18 24 months to pay attention to that
part
Adventure change to learning
adrenaline change to positive tension
and then pivot and adjust that changed
to a little bit crazy because this is
where Founders jump off the roof of
their houses this is where they drive
too fast this is where they get bad
advice
if they're not careful
they end up in the circle to Doom
which is like living in Mordor that
terrible forewording place in The Lord
of the Rings they realize that they are
stuck and this sucks
how did they get here
you know there's a lot happening inside
this Doom
hope deferred makes the heart sick you
started off so hopeful
and now life started happening
this yellow area this is where the devil
lives it also this is where all that
blame lives you know the Market's
terrible your boss is a jerk and all
this kind of thing that's going on
full of this low-grade malaise here just
the energy is being sucked out of you
and then this Doom grows kind of just
hovers around you and can't find a
friend
it's full of Shame and isolation all
right it's depressing enough so let's
get out of this Doom this is how you do
it
you got to delete this from your brain
this brain schema needs to change so
something else
so your destiny the vision of your
future has to be bigger than the current
pain that you can get through anything
your opportunity who said you only need
one maybe four
maybe you need to recheck it maybe it's
time to Pivot
your options how much money do you
actually have what's that what's that
dry powder look like
and also for a mentor
who's speaking into your life
maybe it's time to get another one maybe
it's time to um
find a mentor with some scars in this
area
oh Prosperity success the green Line's
going up don't quit now you're nearly
there you just need to get out of the
circle of Doom
so switch your brain from hitchhiking
mode to adult mode
you do not need another lesson
you need a break and that's coming
improve your grit and tenacity
fell faster and cheaper as we say here
at Stanford
early on I mentioned hope deferred makes
the heart sick
the rest of that is when dreams come
true
there's life
keep growing keep learning
thank you oh before I leave
I need a ride back to my hotel does
anyone have a red Lamborghini
[Applause]
[Music]
oh